right I've got me laptop it's time to
watch a ksi Logan Paul press conference
oh my god the microphones are shocking
[Applause]
still in the lane from stop Monday my
Scottish party started
two-time world champion Shannon the
cannon brick shot in the cotton bricks
are still in it I suppose at least if
I'm being replaced they've done it with
a world heavyweight champion boxer
someone who could fill these shoes I
mean literally that's how high you have
to go up the pecking order in order to
film me still not quite me they don't
all hate each other we just be clear on
that two of them are brothers quite like
each other
the other two I'm not so sure don't
really know the poles I said like
Shannon Briggs money fall he was a real
hard bastard and a lot of knockouts but
then whenever he fought someone he was
like elite-level like a clich bar Louis
he just got schooled
like I'll be honest here and now he's
sort of more famous for just walking
around showman let's go champ
but he's it's a fun thing hovering in
there you know I mean it's good I'm not
bitter I wasn't asked to go earlier let
me just I'm fighting with it it would
have been nice it would have it would
have been lovely boys I should play in
tickets in it
he's saying let's go Chum to himself
once basically and it just solved he
made it his thing but like I think it's
I think it's a bit of a tick from all
the brains how much you've boxed it up
I've gotta be honest yeah I think I saw
that many punches that'sthat's how many
sort of functions now but it's a
wonderful thing I'm not jealous
once again I'm gonna love the audio on
this is [__] shambolic man honestly
[Applause]
what the [__] is Jake pulls here like
seriously mate like if your hairs recede
and I've got deal with it like a man
like don't trying to be fail you've got
that much money they could easily have
that hair transplant [__] why don't
they just do that instead of having this
sort of swirly thing trying to cover up
all the bald patches
what's that suit what is going on me
like I'm a I bet in a suit connoisseur
that looks like a bag of [__] it's like
he's been a tuck by giant birds that
[__] all over a perfectly good black
sloop let's just come out music dad
she's a [__] I mean is that really the
bundle levels were starting with you
this is a downgrade he'll kick himself
when he watches Jeremy Kyle Italia cuz
is that there's a lot of mistakes on
there that are way bigger than dead she
got blood i loved-ed she loved them
because that she's the biggest mistake
of the UK that these responses are you
sure about that it wasn't even like it
wasn't even like you're wrong Jake Paul
they and alluding that the ksi crew
might be gay is really that's the levels
that we're dealing with here as if is it
you know that's appropriate you know me
Oh yogi that is the worst trash talk
microphones not working another
successful day at the production company
wise Jay Paul's I'm gonna and this is so
weird
this is bizarre this is this is really
as a fight fun this is bizarre saying we
thought that this is men I feel like JJ
needs to get on the stage as quick as
possible they're suffering so no
normality did this you know I mean he
knows what he's doing
produce this because the honors the
microphones the volume is [__]
scandalous like this should be [__]
ripped from all their contracts just
chick can you give daddy his glasses
back he actually there are prescription
he needs them so you know Specsavers
Jay Paul sort of showing support for
Tommy Robinson they're the same no gain
Deji
dad you'd have to be very good at games
so if it was you'd be in there's a big
size difference between that gia Jake
like they say there's a good few inches
in height but Jake's just a bigger
person all [__] round so Fair Play
you've got to give credit ed G he's
stunning in the [__] ring but someone
who's gonna be quite a lot bigger than
he doesn't give a [__] no he doesn't
have to win to win if that makes sense
like he's such an underdog for me and
this that if dad you just get in the
ring is fair one and then if he actually
does well and even gets to a decision
then I think he comes out with more
credit than [__] injectors because Jake
should steamrolled edgy in terms of size
difference it should not even be a
competition
wise wise Jack shouting mock Walmart I
don't know if he's got brand deal with
this is the third time you just said dad
you the same [__] question I'm gonna
in their mind that is big serious as
[__] this is real beef this is real sad
like a true butcher he's interrupting me
and said that these lads don't like each
other I think we [__] pick that one
up me you know we've been watching the
internet for the last six months
do you know like this is the thing a lot
of people are actually currently
tweeting me saying you should be hosting
this I'm not saying I should but someone
who understands it and there might have
been a good choice love you love you
Sean he said when you were with Melissa
you in satisfying personal I like it son
the fact that I keep saying Walmart is
really annoying me I'm kind of glad I
wasn't there and where Shannon Briggs is
because I want to slap the [__] myself
to be honest repeat everything that she
says as if we still not in a good way
I've gotta be honest you're wearing
heels Cahill's like them these days oh
you can still find them to be fair
there's not that much of a height
differences there I mean realistically I
Jay Paul is thicker set guy who like
just simple as he's gonna have more
power there's just there's no two ways
about it he's gonna hit harder daddy's
just gonna have to be fast as [__]
little money
Oh tape job wasn't it dead she just had
to go up closer he doesn't say so over
those glasses just to check he's talking
to Jay I'm not shutting I don't feel
like they're getting in each other's
head enough really there's not enough
talk and there's just a lot of shouting
and childish crap he did used to work on
the Disney Channel so what do you expect
today was 250 pounds of chub - no I mean
he wasn't shredded I think daddy's
almost like wow like he's in almost
shock of water correct now this Jay Paul
lad is like he's a parody of himself and
dad Jesus almost like what the [__] he
doesn't know what to say looking like
he's never seen a pair of like a Brian
is [__] entire life I literally could
not have I don't think I should have
been here
the more I watch it what the [__] do you
do when two people are like the fact
that Jay has just said to be done you
know it's a tenor and stop training them
means he's very aware of who Vitale's
and what in what the dance doing with
some behind the scenes and so like
that's interesting
but he's taken an interest that much
that he even knows who's training them
the five first name the dolls are very
[__] good trainer as well by the
looks of it so it must bother him a
little bit we don't know who the [__]
trained and the poles general I mean
he's such a [__] showman is New Jersey
cameraman thinks of adults Gigi no idea
who the [__] we put the camera well do
the production team once again
JD's telling daddy relax
[Applause]
Shannon Briggs doesn't Fort Lee is like
I just feel like he's a military it's
good for him I'll probably be doing the
same thing that we feel like look at
that trick honestly it's Martha his hey
so basically his hairline is so far back
that he has to like sweep it all forward
and then they kill off this front so
there doesn't drop right down on his
[__] forehead his hair is such a
weird I've never seen anyone sort of
have to control all their hair in a way
of hiding their bald patches and still
manage to make it look like they've got
a natural hair it's so bizarre is I find
the hairs really weird like just look me
I mean just shave it they must really
give a [__] about their image a lot if
Chewelah had done that I JJ I think JJ
would have probably reacted a lot more
so we're saying someone who is more
self-confident and trying to be the
bully than what Joe did and if anything
I think would be another way around with
JJ and Joseph it's kind of interest in
that chin I mean but I don't think for a
second
JJ fears I think it's just more like
he's willing to play the game this time
whereas last time it was about I was
more personal laughing
to be fair those shades are actually all
right
literally the amount of effort that
haircut mistake like tequila or he must
have to put those Rawley things in that
all little old ladies put in just to
stop his hair from like fallen on his
it's bizarre it's weird because when
they were in the night club the other
night there's a little video come out
where JJ is right up against Logan and
Logan's like every time I see you I get
less and less scared and it's like
alright so you're admitting that you're
scared and like it when there's no
cameras in there or less cameras you
could tell he was a bit more intimidated
but now I think he feels like everyone
would jump on me and stop anything from
going far he's acting a lot more
confident now and I feel like it is
enough JJ literally got in the inspired
with Mike Bisping like what he's not
gonna give a [__] about Logan Paul
sousou a 10 year old cousin Jake Paul
Amy didn't want to fight he blew me
[__] don't like size-wise JJ and Jake
would have been the right fight to make
in terms of weight and ejected mana
didn't wind in my face literally
Shannon's lost it here like no one can
get a [__] word in like as the media
you have to tell people when it's their
turn to talk this is just it's gone now
I mean and tweeted now like why where
are you why on you yeah constantly
you know what that's a [__] ode to
what he did the little prick so that's
the first time Logan's shut up because
it's actually about something that he
[__] did you remember that's the hut
that Logan was wearing when he went into
the suicide forest
JJ's just politely reminded him you knew
this wasn't gonna be like a proper fight
press conference but even still the
polls of made this so [__] panda mine
it's unbelievable I want to hear more
about what they wanted to do to each
other like what what they think about
each other a lot of this is just a silly
innit Gina Shannon should be trying to
get more answers out of them and try and
actually get them to try and get in each
other's head what's happening is JJ is
really good at getting like
psychologically into his opponents head
he's really good at talking about you as
a person and he's not getting the chance
to do any of that because this is just
the poor brother screaming and showing
and Shannon Briggs is just sitting there
letting it happen Jay it's not really
know how I would like this to go down
the toilet roll of JJ's face on YouTube
for Toby he's like I I want to know how
trainings go and I want to know the
weaknesses that they say in each other
little things about what they think of
each other's personalities like this is
more Mendel's going Fred now he's trying
to get into his rhythm it's taking a
while or because they obviously the
crowd screaming a time or whatever then
those two imbeciles across from him I
tried to [__] scream them down he's
getting into
oh he's gone he's got the blood JJ looks
so funny in that [__] I love the fact
that JJ is directing everyone Xena was
the shot that he wants to go out on the
internet after this is all done just
courted the video that Logan released
after the suicide for his videos and
basically like the piece of them that
spits Logan of that much he's just
ripped the wig off that's really [__]
him off that is really God finally this
is getting in their skin big table
always went for the bandanna
JJ's [__] losing it now everyone's on
the [__] stage now foxy
if anything went down it Vidal would
pretty much knock every [__] that's
really what's whoa look at him he's
[__] and JJ not a [__] blink like
he doesn't give a [__] he's right in his
face he doesn't give a [__] to be fair I
don't think anyone was trying to swing
at each other there but I think Logan
couldn't help but put his hands on JJ
because he was that is a humiliating
memory from the fact that he had this
dude that video after the suicide forest
right now he's trying to play the alpha
male and that is humiliation he did he
wants everyone to forget about that no
one will ever forget about that ever and
that's why so many people want JJ the
[__] wreck him in this fight not the
best way to end it it was a bit like the
first press conference between Weller
and JJ but not not quite as good Jenna
and I mean it was just but there was
some good moments in there that you know
getting under the skin
a little bit but from a press conference
you want to see someone get a
psychological advantage the only thing
that happened there was JJ really won't
[__] out the login at one point in logon
was the one who snapped it logan
couldn't handle it and i think there's a
little window into what JJ can exploit
in the next press conference if i
mustard baby i'm to be honest i'm gonna
be apprehensive about this kids like i
want to be part of something good and
that to me was like you know there was
some good moments but there was bits
where it was embarrassing you know I'm
saying so hopefully the fights are going
to be good I actually think the fights
are going to be good because these [__]
are so [__] competitive that they're
gonna have to train their ass off and I
know for a fact JJ's gonna be ready so a
Logan better be [__] ready basically
and a [__] really really want JJ to
beat Logan honestly I've had a lot of
fights I've watched in my time where I
really want someone to win I've never
wanted someone to win this badly before
cuz Logan what he did was disgusting and
within for the UK especially we need JJ
let's [__] do this for us alot like
big-time bull he's up against a physical
challenge yeah like Logan is a big lad
JJ's gonna have to use every bit of
skill he's learned in the last year and
a half to [__] pull this off Jay Paul
dead G on the other hand I feel like
there's a massive advantage for Jake in
terms of physical jet Deji just isn't no
way in the air as big as him but I just
think you should go for a points
decision just job move move around the
ring
don't let him pin you down into the
corner whatever the [__] and just fight
as quick as you possibly [__] can I'm
excited I'm excited for this I know a
lot of people are gonna look at this and
say it's a joke but this is massive for
YouTube it is [__] huge and I think I
might be commenting on it so I'm not in
forward with the overall take homes from
that press conference is wasn't great
let's be honest I mean was a bit they
were there was submits I really liked
but there was a few embarrassing bits as
well the main takeaway from it has gotta
be the fact that Logan was so annoyed
and embarrassed at what JJ was doing
impersonate him that he couldn't help
but put his hands on him that means he's
not fully in control of his emotions
you've seen when
come close to JJ JJ did it in him flinch
he's in control he's been in the ring
enough to have to control his emotions
and I think that that experience is
going to benefit him a lot I'm not
saying it's gonna win the fight for him
but it conned him it's only gonna help
him login on the other hand he's gonna
have to [__] catch J job as quick as
he possibly can if he wants a chance in
this fight because that's foreign video
I seen basic at best I mean he was
throwing punches wildly so many of them
didn't land or ie drop them and stagger
them but you're not gonna catch JJ like
that that's not gonna be good enough to
beat JJ that footage I seen they might
have really started make him look worse
they might have released it to make him
look better they may have released it
just because it's the only time he's
[__] dropped someone yet we don't
know all I've got is that footage to go
off and it didn't look great
JJ is the better boxer no doubt would be
made about that but Logan's got the
physical advantage Jake versus Deji on
the other hand edg's early footage look
[__] terrible there's just no other
way you can describe it but he's told
this he's a lot bad Jake on the other
hand massive physical advantage but you
might be [__] [__] boxing I don't
know what the [__] gonna happen dad
she just needs to be fast and go for a
points decision don't try and knock the
kiddo just land and move get the [__]
out of the way of the big shots I'm
really excited for this I know a lot of
young girls think it's cringe-worthy
there's a little bit of times obviously
they're not professional fighters but I
think that when these lads get in the
ring they're going to give it everything
because egotistical e none of them want
to be humiliated and there's every
chance that that could happen and if it
does there's so much for them to lose
general I mean they have to go in there
I think dead G's the only person who's
pretty safe here because dead G is a
funny [__] guy and he's massively at
a disadvantage physically the rest of
them have all got something to lose yeah
so that's what makes this muscle as well
as the views as well as the fact that
hopefully I'll be commenting so fingers
crossed
just let let you wash tip that's it
anyway hope you've enjoyed this video if
you have hit the like button subscribe
thanks for watching
and I'll say as Lena